اعلمت السلطات الفرنسيه مقتل واصابه اربعه
باطلاق نار بشارع دانجين في منطقه الدائره
العاشره في العاصمه باريس
واشارت سائل اعلام الفرنسيه الى ان
الحادثه وقع امام مركز استقبال اللاجئين
اكراد في العاصمه وقال للدعاء العام انه
يبحث في دوافع عنصريه على خلفيه الحادث
واكد وزير الداخليه الفرنسي جيرارد
اعتقال المشتبهي به بتنفيذ الهجوم الذي
قال مكتب للدعاء العام انه يبلغ 69 عاما
وقد سبق للمشتبع به وتورط في محاولتي قتل
واشارت الى انه وسائل على اشاره لانه هاجم
قبل عام مركز العلاجيه
باريس ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حسين
القنيبر حسين مرحبا بك ضعنا اولا في اخر
التطورات والمعلومات حول هذه الحادث
اهلا بك يا خالد ابدا بالجديد الذي يتمثل
في اعلان مصدر امني قبل دقائق قليله من
الان ان عدد ضحايا اعتداء باريس قادر
ارتفع الى ثلاثه قتله عدد الجرحى ثلاثه
ايضا احدهم في حال الخطر واثنان اخران
مصابان بجراح متوسطه كنت ذكرت خلال
المداخله معك خالد بعد دقائق من وقوع
الاعتداء ان الرجل اطلق النار المعتدي
اطلق النار قرب مركز كردي ولكن لم نكن
نعرف طبيعه هذا المركز ومدى العلاقه بينما
فعله المعتدي وهذا المركز الكردي تبين لنا
الان ان اطلاق النار وقع في جوار المركز
الثقافي الكردي هنا في شارع اونجا في
الدائره العاشره في العاصمه الفرنسيه لهذا
الحي لهذه الدائره عموما الدائره العاشره
خ
تتمثل في كونها كانت احدى المناطق التي
طاولتها اعتداءات الثالث عشر من نوفمبر من
العام 2015
والتي كانت عباره عن سلسله اعتداءات في
دائرتين العاشره والحاديه عشر في باريس
وفي ملعب ستاند فرانس الشهير وايضا مسرح
بتلوم هذه المنطقه كانت واحده من المناطق
التي استهدفت حينها المدعى العامه في
باريس اوضحت وهذا كلام مهم تتطابق معك مع
كان ذاكرته مصادر امنيه ان المعتدي نفسه
كان قام باعتداء على مخيم للمهاجرين في
باريس في الثامن من ديسمبر من العام
الماضي اي قبل عام
والثلاثه عشر يوما قبل عام
وخمسه عشر يوما قام بالاعتداء على مخيم
للاجئين في الدائره الثانيه عشر في باريس
كما اعتدى على مهاجرين ايضا في ضاحيه
بيرسي القريبه من العاصمه الفرنسيه وحينها
فتحت تحقيق في الاعتداء الذي قام به وليس
معروفا سببه وجوده حرا طليقا الان هل لانه
استفاده من افراج مشروط عنه ام لانه كان
يخضع لمراقبه قضائيه نجح في الاسلام منها
كل ذلك قيد التحقق حاليا من قبل الشرطه
وزير الداخليه الفرنسي جلال دار الموجود
الذي كان موجود في تركيا شمال فرنسا سيعود
الى العاصمه الفرنسيه وسيصل الى هنا الى
هذا المكان بعد قليل للادلاء بتصريحات
طبعا ما كان اعلن ايضا هو انه لم يعثر
بحوزه المعتدي على اوراق ثبوتيه تحدد
جنسيته لكن ما ذكر ايضا انه قام باكثر من
اعتداء له طبيعه عنصريه اذا ثبتت هذه
المعلومات واصبحت رسميه ونهائيه فان للامر
دلالات مختلفه وتحقيق يتخذ مجرا اخر هذه
المره خالد يعني هل من المعتاد تكرار مثل
هذه الحوادث ان يكون شخص متهم وله ثوابق
همم ان يكون حرا طليقا ربما يقوم بمثل هذه
الاعمال في فرنسا حسين
لوزاره الداخليه والشرطه بعض الذين قاموا
باعتداءات في شوارع باريس ومدن فرنسيه
اخرى كانت لهم ثوابق وهذا كان موضع انتقاد
من جهات عده من احزاب وايضا من مواطنين
استغربوا ان يكون اشخاص قاموا بما قاموا
به تمكنوا من الافلات من العقاب وتمكنوا
من تعريض حياه الناس للخطر مجددا اذكر
ايضا خالد في المعلومات الوارده الينا ان
المعتدي الذي قام باعتدائه حواله ثانيه 10
ظهرا بالتوقيت المحلي اخرج من كيس كان
يحمله مسدسا اسودا وراح يطلق النار من هذا
المسدس قبل ان يتمكن عدد من الاشخاص من
السيطره عليه